welcome to chess.com the number one
chess site where every day tens of
thousands of chess players from around
the world come to play chess learn new
strategies and openings and share their
love of the game chess.com is for all
chess players from beginner to master
it's free and easy to get started
everything is web-based so there's
nothing to download
jump into live chats for fast play and
live chat with your opponent from one
minute bullet or five minute blitz
on up to hour long games you can play
any speed you want too fast
then play on limited turn-based games
from 1 to 14 days per move
you get rated as you play and your stats
in progress are continually tracked when
you're ready to take it to the next
level enter tournaments where you can
win cool trophies and show who's king
or join other chess.com members for team
versus team tournaments
[Music]
chess.com helps you learn with tools for
everyone from beginner to master
study openings with the game explorer
that not only analyzes millions of
master level games but lets you explore
the games you've played on chess.com
improve your tactical vision with more
than ten thousand chess problems and
puzzles in the interactive tactics
trainer when you're really ready to take
your game to the next level train with
chess mentor the most effective chess
training tool ever created
get custom feedback on every possible
move in thousands of lessons written by
grand masters and teachers like jeremy
silman you'll get detailed analysis of
the strengths and weaknesses in your
game
you can also improve by reading hundreds
of free articles covering everything
from famous games to best strategies
or stay current on the latest chess news
and famous tournaments from around the
world or check out the chess blogs
posted by otherchess.com members
if you're looking for some chess action
in your neighborhood check out our local
section where you can find local
tournaments a nearby club where you can
sit down for a game
or a local chess coach to give you
personal instruction
in the resources section you can
download free chess programs
read reviews of chess books and
equipment or find a place to buy chess
stuff online
the real heart of chess.com is the
community here you can create your
personal profile and tell all about
yourself and show off your favorite
games you can add friends send messages
blog on your chess thoughts and fully
customize the way chess.com looks
you'll also find hundreds of private
groups for anyone from chess historians
to hockey fans groups can challenge each
other to matches or use private forums
to keep in touch and speaking of forums
chess.com has the most active chess
forums on the internet discuss
everything from openings to game
showcase to off topic
literally thousands of chess players
post every day you can even insert games
diagrams or puzzles right into your
posts this makes it easy to get valuable
feedback and analysis on your games
alright i've said enough i know why
you're here to play chess
come join the hundreds of thousands of
chess players that have already
connected on chess.com it's free and
super easy what are you waiting for sign
up and get started playing right now
see you soon